but there is a problem there's a big
problem by the way facing the Republican
party and that problem happens to be
that the largest voting Block in the
United States Millennials and Generation
Z voters
absolutely despise the Republican Party
new data has come out from the 2022
election that tells us
that 77 percent of Generation Z voters
said they voted for a Democratic
candidate for congress last year versus
only 21 percent who said they voted for
a Republican
so we've got a 77 to 21 percent
split between Generation Z voters alone
and of course Millennials maybe not that
extreme but still overwhelmingly vote
for Democrats those two blocks combined
now make up the largest voting Block in
the United States outnumbering the Baby
Boomers which happens to be the largest
voting block for the Republicans
Republicans also have the added I don't
want to call it tragedy but I guess it
is a tragedy of the fact that they let a
lot of their followers and supporters
die
during the pandemic
they were out there trashing vaccines
they were out there telling people ah
you don't have to wear a mask that's
oppression
and they saw a lot of their voters a lot
of their supporters a lot of their core
base die off
because of that
and I think by the way that is a
statistic it's a grim statistic but
that's something that most people
completely ignored during the 2022
midterms I mean I talked about it a lot
because study after study after study
showed us that the coveted death rates
in red areas of the country red counties
were exponentially higher than in blue
counties
that may be one of the reasons why
Republicans who a year ago were
predicting a 70-seat pickup in the house
only have a couple seats in their
majority
I think that's something that needs to
be taken into consideration especially
since we still have people dying in this
country of covid and those deaths are
the overwhelmingly unvaccinated part of
the population
so Republicans have a problem with their
voting block because they're still
letting them die off and then they got a
problem with the young voters who want
nothing to do with the Republican Party
and the reason of course is because
young voters the Millennials and the
Generation Z voters overwhelmingly
support action on gun control
they overwhelmingly support taking
action on the issue of climate change
they overwhelmingly
support lgbtq issues they support access
to abortion they support all of the
things that Republicans have openly
declared war on here in the United
States and what's funny is that the
Republicans have obviously
you know acknowledge this
but here is what Ronald McDaniel the
chair of the Republican National
Committee had to say
when we do when we do that and we talk
about Economic Opportunity the things
our party stands for we'll win those
voters over
we just have to compete for them
see here's the problem with your plan
Rana first of all it's it's completely
wrong anyway
second of all
you don't have a plan
to pitch to these voters
you don't have a plan to pitch to any
voters right now the only plans we're
hearing about from the Republican Party
are let's raise the retirement age for
the young people let's make them just
keep working and working and working and
working and Nikki Haley has that plan
she's she said that in a speech recently
republicans in Congress suggested it
like let's just raise the retirement age
you think that generation that has no
nothing but hardship and Wars based on
lies and pandemics throughout their
whole lives do you think they want to
hear that
but beyond that what is your plan what
is your economic plan Republicans can
anyone watching this tell me what a
republican economic plan is
and tell me who is pushing it and what
it would do for the country anyone
the answer is no you can't because such
a thing doesn't exist
I am 40 years old throughout my lifetime
Republicans
have had one plan other than outside of
culture War stuff I'm talking about one
actual legislative plan my entire life
that one plan has been to cut
taxes
it's been trickle-down economics my
entire life every time Republicans get
power the first thing they want to do is
cut taxes
we've already seen the Republican
majority in the House of Representatives
proposed cutting taxes again extending
the Trump tax cuts
it doesn't work and this generation
knows it this generation isn't afraid to
call it out
they're not buying into those lies of
Reaganomics
and they're angry and as long as
Republicans continue to push that
they will never attract these younger
Generations
we have to take a quick break I'm Farren
cousins again you can subscribe to my
YouTube channels at youtube.com the ring
of fire and youtube.com fair and
balanced and I'm on Twitter Instagram
Tick Tock and Facebook at fair and
balanced we'll be right back with more
on the David packman show